whether it's through a jump scare or a
twist ending horror is a genre that
tends to trade on the element of
surprise everyone remembers leaping out
of their chair the first time the dog
jumped through the window in Resident
Evil or the first time they were grabbed
by Lisa in PT
for many that surprise accompanied with
the fist clenching jolt through your
body is a crucial part of the experience
of playing a horror game one game that
attempts to capture that same horrifying
sensation but within a multiplayer
setting is dead by daylight as a game
where a player could end up playing
thousands of matches over the course of
hundreds of hours of Play Time
maintaining that feeling of surprise
seems like a challenge so how does
Behavior interactive hope to keep dead
by daylight scary years after release
according to Dave Richard the game's
creative director dead by daylight
harnesses something you won't find in
most other horror titles real human
nature it's all about real human doing
real human stuff and so it's absolutely
unpredictable
[Music]
when it comes to the pantheon of horror
games dead by daylight is pretty unique
in the last six years it's attracted
over 50 million players and expanded
into a pop culture horror sandbox
complete with dozens of characters from
Iconic horror franchises since the
game's launch in 2016 Dave Richard has
been in charge of corralling these
elements into a cohesive whole my job is
to make sure the team has great content
to work with that they're motivated that
are inspired and so I will receive
pretty much all of the new content that
we're adding to that by their life if
you haven't played it the horror genre
might seem like an unnatural fit for
this kind of live service multiplayer
title but dead by Daylight's gameplay is
closer to something like hide and seek
than a traditionally crafted horror
experience that might sound like a
criticism but even though we tend to
think of them as children's games like
hide and seek are well understood
examples of recreational fear the
phenomenon of rehearsing our anxiety
responses through play we've designed
the game around hide and seek and for us
a lot of the Great Moments came from
Survivor hiding in the bush because he
hears the heartbeat of you know the
Killer and because the Killer is in
first person he's gonna have like issues
finding that Survivor or he doesn't even
know that it's there and there's going
to be like a close call where some the
killer just passed by and these are
great moments of fear for the Survivor
but of course uh dead by daylight is not
a certain play like that it's it's more
played as a like a tag game it's really
more about Chase as it's frantic and and
so it's more about stress and fear of
getting caught than the actual stealth
approach to it when we play games like
Dead by daylight we're activating
ancient biological mechanisms to help us
Escape danger the stakes may be virtual
but the psychological and physiological
effects you feel when you're being
chased or hiding are very real and have
even been shown to provide long-lasting
benefits for emotional regulation why
not check out our previous episode of
Mind Games all about that subject
however this free-form tag style of
gameplay means that unlike most horror
games there are no big set piece horror
scares in in dead by daylight to use the
earlier example there are no signature
dog through window moments that every
player shares it may have a Grizzly
horror aesthetic and plenty of Gore but
it's a strange example of a horror game
that isn't really looking to craft any
specific horror moments instead Behavior
hopes that by creating a Sandbox for
killers and survivors to play around in
the creativity of players will generate
those heart-pounding horror set pieces
in an organic way be it through a
Survivor making a narrow Escape or
falling victim to an unexpected trap we
have a multiplayer setting and so that
was a key component for us right from
the start in our very first videos that
we've communicated about our game we
took pride in the fact that our game did
not have a fear system it's all about
real human doing real human stuff and so
it's absolutely unpredictable on top of
that through the years we've added so
much more components and everything in
that by daylight is mix and match so it
creates this amazing chaos and diversity
we wanted to create a game where every
single game can create a unique story
that the player will be able to talk
about afterwards to you know their
friends The Killers themselves are not
only drawn from beloved pop culture
franchises but well-worn horror tropes
too I'd argue that Killers like the
spirit the nurse and the hillbilly all
where their influence is pretty
obviously on their sleeve but with each
addition to the roster Dave and his team
hope to add variation and Novelty to
keep players having fun and being scared
years after their first match another
way to crash these horror scenarios is
through the powers of the different
Killers When we create these Powers we
always have a type of fear in mind or a
type of scenario that we want to create
or multiple type of scenarios so an
example like Michael Myers the fact that
e-boost is Power by being quite stealthy
and just watching this creates these
great moments where you feel watch and
when you finally see that white mask in
the background you freak out right and
you wonder how long it was there how
long the danger was lurking another
example to the complete opposite is the
hag the hack is creating these traps
that when they're triggered a version of
her appears and it creates that jump
scare moment so these very different
type scenarios are created with the
different powers that the killers have
for me I would say that tailty Killers
such as Myers the pig Ghost Face even
the dredge you know that can surprise
you by popping or just by being very
passive are truly as scary experiences
speaking personally the combination of
its somewhat obtuse mechanics with its
horror characters and aesthetic May
trying to play dead by daylight as
someone new to the game this year an
incredibly daunting experience it's
never easy to learn the ropes in a
multiplayer game and usually that
involves dying a lot
thank you
but when combined with several years
worth of killers each with their own
skills and perks I found it incredibly
difficult to get my footing in a weird
way this all contributed to the unique
feeling of horror dead by daylight
generates it's undeniably thrilling when
you manage to just escape the clutches
of a killer with a well-timed vault or
even by simply hiding in plain sight
even though you're convinced you've
already been spotted this
player-on-player battle of nerves is
what makes dead by daylight unique even
if I'm really really bad at it
dead by daylight is unique as a horror
game because of its chaos created by
human players that all have their
different personalities using these
tools will create scenarios that are
different every time and so the the
horror and the stress that's created
will also be varied and different if
you've played a few horror games before
they tend to settle into a kind of
Rhythm if you've just been scared you
can usually guarantee everything's gonna
calm down for you might even recognize
the tropes and beats enough to know when
the next big scare is coming
but in dead by daylight because you know
every other player is human it's much
harder to give yourself that feeling of
security as a Survivor you're at the
mercy of whatever unique psychological
makeup and gaming skills the player
hunting you happens to have in that way
it feels like Dave and everyone at
Behavior could craft as many deranged
Killers as they like but the scariest
thing about dead by daylight will always
be the unpredictable human being you're
playing against it's a funny thing now
that I have kids a lot of uh like uh
trivial fears have disappeared
completely from my life which is one
thing I miss too no I I used to like
being scared a little bit of the dark
because I'm in my house I'm a little bit
scared of the dark because I've seen a
movie
um you know but I'm safe so it's it's
fine it's a good it's a good feeling
um but I don't I don't get that anymore